intelligence is scary intelligent agents
are scary when I'm in the woods the
scariest animal to meet is a human right
no no no there's look there's like nice
California humans like I see you're
wearing like you know street clothes and
Nikes all right fine but you look like
you've been a human who's been in the
woods for a while yeah I'm more scared
of you than a bear that's what they say
about the Amazon when you go to the
Amazon it's the human tribes oh yeah
so intelligence is scary right so to
just like ask this question in a generic
way you're like what if we took
everybody who you know maybe has um ill
intention but is not so intelligent and
gave them intelligence
right
so we should have intelligence control
of course we should only give
intelligence to good people and that is
the absolutely horrifying idea since you
the best defense is actually the best
defense is to give more intelligence to
the good guys and intelligence give
intelligence to everybody give
intelligence to everybody you know what
it's not even like guns right like
people say this about guns you know
what's what's the best defense against a
bag over the gun good guy with a gun
like I kind of subscribe to that but I
really subscribe to that with
intelligence
yeah in a fundamental way I agree with
you but there's just feels like so much
uncertainty and so much can happen
rapidly that you can lose a lot of
control you can do a lot of damage oh no
we can lose control yes thank God yeah I
hope we can I hope they lose control
I'd want them to lose control more than
anything else
I think when you lose control you can do
a lot of damage but you can do more
damage when you centralize and hold on
to control is the point centralized and
held control is tyranny right I will
always I don't like Anarchy either but
I'll always take Anarchy over tyranny
Anarchy have a chance
this human civilization we've got going
on is quite interesting I mean I agree
with you so do you open source
is the way forward here so you admire
what Facebook is doing here or what Matt
is doing with the release of them yeah a
lot I lost I've lost eighty thousand
dollars last year investing in meta and
when they released llama I'm like yeah
whatever man that was worth it it's
worth it
do you think Google and uh open AI with
Microsoft will match what what meta is
doing or no
so if I were a researcher why would you
want to work at open AI like you know
you're just you're on the bad team like
I mean it like you're on the bad team
who can't even say that gpt4 has 220
billion parameters so closed source to
use the bad team
not only closed Source I'm not saying
you need to make your model weights open
I'm not saying that I totally understand
we're keeping our model weights closed
because that's our product right
I'm saying like because of AI safety
reasons we can't tell you the number of
billions of parameters in the model
that's just the bad guys
just because you're mocking AI safety
doesn't mean it's not real oh of course
is it possible that these things can
really do a lot of damage that we don't
know oh my God yes intelligence is so
dangerous be it human intelligence or
machine intelligence intelligence is
dangerous to put machine intelligence is
so much easier to deploy at scale like
rapidly
like what okay if you have human-like
bots on Twitter all right
and you have like a thousand of them
create a whole narrative
like you can manipulate millions of
people but you mean like the
intelligence agencies in America are
doing right now yeah but they're not
doing it that that well it feels like
you can do a lot they're doing it pretty
well
what I think they're doing a pretty good
job I I suspect they're not nearly as
good as a bunch of uh gbt fueled Bots
could be well I mean of course they're
looking into the latest Technologies for
control of people of course but I think
there's a George Haas type character
that can do a better job than the
entirety of the you don't think so why
no and I'll tell you why the George hotz
character can't and I thought about this
a lot with hacking right like I can find
exploits in web browsers I probably
still can I mean I was better I know I
was 24 but the thing that I lack is the
ability to slowly and steadily deploy
them over five years and this is what
intelligence agencies are very good at
right intelligence agencies don't have
the most sophisticated technology
they just have endurance endurance
yeah the financial backing and the
infrastructure for the endurance so the
more we can decentralize power like you
can make an argument by the way that
nobody should have these things and I
would defend that argument I would I
would like you saying look llms and Ai
and machine intelligence can cause a lot
of harm so nobody should have it and I
will respect someone philosophically
with that position just like I will
respect someone philosophically with the
position that nobody should have guns
right but I will not respect
philosophically which it with with
Only The Trusted authorities should have
access to this yeah who are The Trusted
authorities you know what I'm not
worried about alignment between
AI company and their machines I'm
worried about alignment between me and
AI company